it's been more than a week since deadly
tornadoes ripped through Tennessee
communities are still picking up the
pieces including Nashville the country
music capital of the world Don Dahler
shows us how an iconic guitar company is
helping this city heal Nashville is
still reeling from the killer tornadoes
that plowed through town on March 3rd
parts of Music City will take months to
rebuild but as Garth Brooks told nor
O'Donnell they don't have help in any
kind of recovery or anything music is
usually the first one called
and in that town it's a pretty safe bet
that they're going to show up and they
have recording artists like Taylor Swift
dan + Shay as well as other musicians
who took part in a telethon that raised
at least one and a half million dollars
grammy-nominated artist Brandi Clark
lives in Nashville's what is it about a
tragedy like this that brings out the
best in people I choose to believe that
most of us are good and it just comes
down to our hearts and you know wanting
to help out another human famed
instrument maker Gibson is helping by
donating guitars to anyone who lost
theirs in the storm the band good-bye
June received the very tools they use to
make a living it brings joy back you
know and it helps it is just meaningful
acts like this that helps the healing
process for the band and others March
3rd will not be remembered as the day
the music died Don Dahler CBS News New
York